¿Qué país puede montar ahora mismo, con la Premier League actual, el mejor once posible?
Hoy lo vas a descubrir.
Andrés, la guerra de las naciones.
La guerra de las naciones.
Un gallego con suadera.
Un madrileño manga corta.
Eres una vergüenza para tu tierra.
Debo decir que ha sido sentarme ante los focos y estoy asándome de calor.
Pero una vez hemos asumido esto, yo ya voy a acabar este vídeo con suadera como inaugurando la época de suaderas de Madrid.
Me acabo de acordarte una cosa.
¿De qué cosa?
Estoy metiéndome entre pecho y espalda estos días la serie de Farinha.
¡Oh! Seriaza.
Javi... ¿cómo se llama el...?
Muchas referencias al Z de Vigo y al Dépor.
Uno de los jugadores del equipo de Sito Meñanco es el padre de Braz Mendes.
¡No jodas! No sabía yo esto.
Bueno, de igual. No puedo hacer spoilers.
Una cosa que me gusta es entender lo que dicen porque disfruto mucho pensando en gente que ha aprendido español,
extranjera, un inglés de la vida, que dice, guay, a control del español, que lleva viviendo en España cinco años.
Te pones farinha y estoy seguro que a Laureano Ubiña no entiendes ni una palabra.
Y a Charlin, que...
¡Guay! Y yo ahí diciendo, qué bien que les entiendo.
¡Jodete, extranjero, que crees que sabes español y no sabes nada!
Esto es como cuando nosotros escuchamos una peli irlandesa.
¿Qué no entendemos de una palabra?
Pues también es muy buena en ese aspecto la serie esta que hace Luis Taera con José Coronado,
que es la de Sin Permiso, creo, o Vivir Sin Permiso o algo así, que también está basada en Galicia.
Y también, bueno, Luis Taera...
¡Que te voy a contar a ti! ¡Joder!
Sí, siempre con la voz así.
¡Joder! ¡Dios!
Bueno, amigos, pues nada. Volvemos al tema, ¿vale?
Hemos hablado un poco de Galicia.
Y ahora vamos a hablar de países y Premier League, porque nos hemos planteado la siguiente cuestión.
Si hiciéramos una guerra de naciones, si peleásemos, pusiéramos a pelear, mejor dicho,
países representados en la Premier League formando once solo con esas nacionalidades,
¿cuál sería el mejor país? El que puede montar un mejor once.
Y esto es un encargo que le hemos hecho a Andrés Valls.
Hay que decir que este vídeo ya existe en su forma histórica, que la hizo Pablo hace un tiempo.
Recomiendo que lo vayáis a ver. Nosotros vamos a hacer, como ha dicho Nacho, con el de ahora.
Y por eso es importante empezar viendo qué selecciones han clasificado a este mundial.
Haciendo un proceso de clasificación habitual.
Estas son las selecciones que se han clasificado con el mundial con dos cuestiones a comentar.
Porque Italia y Suecia tienen once jugadores en la Premier League, pero Italia tiene dos porteros.
Claro. Buquermo Vicario y Donnarumma. He intentado buscar si alguno de ellos había sido centrocampista o algo así.
Nada nos habría gustado más.
Habría sido increíble y Suecia no tiene ningún portero.
Entonces Suecia y Italia no participan en este mundial. Las otras once sí.
¿Nilan no era sueco?
Nilan diría que es noruego.
Y no está en la...
Era por apurar de...
Es noruego. Orian Nilan.
¿Y Olsen?
Robin Olsen, pero tampoco se fue este verano.
Ya, pero digo que lo hemos rozado.
Sí, sí. Habría sido increíble.
Pero también si lo hubiéramos hecho el año pasado habríamos perdido Italia, por ejemplo. Donnarumma no ha llegado hasta el año pasado.
Bueno, ahí veis que hay selecciones. Evidentemente a la Premier League he puesto más 150.
Porque es muy difícil ponerse a contar una por una.
Luego, cosas curiosas.
El hecho de Alemania, que hay una brecha importante entre España y Alemania.
Hay Argentina, por ejemplo, con esos seis de diferencia.
Y una cosa que sí os diré.
No por tener más, se tiene mejor equipo.
Aunque, sí por tener menos, se tiene peor.
Así que, si te parece Nacho, vamos a empezar con el peor equipo.
Con la peor selección, la que quedaría última.
Me duele mucho.
Perdóname, Andrés. Me parecen poquísimos escoceses.
Bueno, es que vas a flipar con un dato.
¿Cómo ha cambiado el fútbol inglés?
Que antes estaba hasta arriba de escoceses.
Era la segunda nacionalidad en muchas ocasiones. O la tercera.
Me preguntas sin ver el gráfico.
Y te juro que te habría dicho...
25.
30 escoceses. Poquísimo.
Vale, ahora yo, Nacho, te voy a preguntar una cosa.
Cuántos centrales dirías que hay escoceses en la Premier League?
Ah, sí. Pensándolo rápido.
Sin pensar en jugadores exactos.
Bueno, no sé. Tres. Viendo que son 12.
Vale, vamos a verlo.
Hay cero centrales escoceses en la Premier League.
Que me parece extraordinario.
He tenido que hacer una línea de tres.
Con Harrison Asby, que ha jugado seis partidos en su carrera como central.
Andy Rubinck, que no jugó nunca de central, pero 13 veces de pivote.
Y Andy Robertson, que podemos hacer ahí esa función como central por izquierda más veterano.
Qué drama.
A ver, muy puntualmente ha jugado como central en el Liverpool.
Sí, sí, pero claro.
Pero cuando digo muy puntualmente, está hablando de minutos.
Claro, claro, claro.
Madre mía.
Luego, el delantero.
Chambers no ha debutado todavía en la Premier League desde el 2007.
Vale.
Ben Doack debutó con el Bournemouth al pasado fin de semana ante el Leeds.
Ya había debutado con el Liverpool.
Sí, sí, sí.
Y luego, bueno, Kearney de extremo habilidoso puede quedarse algo corto.
Bueno, me compras...
Se puede hacer el cambio de Kearney por McKean y también se puede entender.
Sí, sí, pero bueno.
Pero bueno.
Wow.
Bueno, Ryan Christie en su día era extremo.
Sí.
Entonces, bueno...
A ver, fútbol líquido, ¿no?
A ver, ninguno de los cambios que te propongo hace que Escocia no se vaya a llevar un palazo
en este vídeo.
Joder.
Bueno, porque están juzgando que si no nos montaría once.
Hostias, para lo que ha quedado a Escocia.
Es duro, es duro, es duro.
Hombre, Escocia...
En los inicios del fútbol inglés, sobre todo el profesionalismo, normalmente los jugadores
más codiciados eran los escoceses.
Y de hecho, los primeros que hacían los triquiñolas para decir, bueno, esto es fútbol amateur,
estaba prohibido el profesionalismo, pero...
Pero trabaja aquí.
Te pagamos por detrás.
Eran escoceses y estaban muy cotizados.
Y fíjate para lo que queda a Escocia.
Tremendo, ¿eh?
Lo que hacen 150 años de evolución a Escocia.
Aunque no solo ha pasado esto en Reino Unido con Escocia, ¿vale?
Porque el siguiente país con la peor selección de todas estas seleccionables es Gales, que
tiene un poco mejor de equipo que Escocia, pero tampoco es una cuestión para tirar cohetes,
partiendo de la base de que Beban no ha debutado todavía este temporada con el Bournemouth
y Roberts viene de recuperarse de lesión.
Roberts, os podemos asegurar que es él.
¿Qué decir?
Creo que más de uno va a decir, ¿os sabéis si quedó con la foto de Roberts?
Sí, sí, sí.
Os podemos asegurar que ahora tiene ese peinado y ese bigote.
Es que, Nacho, he estado revisando el vídeo antes de venir para aquí, las diapositivas,
y he dicho, esto me he equivocado.
He buscado con los Roberts y he dicho, me he equivocado claramente de foto.
Pero me compras que es nivel, si lo llega a buscar la policía, se pone este look, es
otro hombre.
¿Os acordáis de...
Joder, que acordaos, cuando estuvo en el Leeds o incluso en el Swansea, es que tenía
otra pinta completamente diferente.
Le ha pasado la vida por encima.
Es tremendo, es tremendo.
Sí, sí, bueno, lo que tiene es subir y bajar con el fútbol.
Ahora, esto te voy a decirte que lo veo mucho más apañado que Escocia, ¿eh?
A ver.
No es una maravilla, no es una maravilla.
Pero, oye, Darlow está jugando en el Leeds.
Es cierto también que está jugando con asterisco, ¿vale?
Porque Perry está lesionado.
Davis, bueno, oye, me parece un jugador que ha hecho buen papel.
Con Beban tengo más dudas de cara a que nos pueda ganar aquí un argumento.
Pero luego todo lo demás, Nico Williams, Roberts, Joe Rodon, defensa de tres, Ampadu,
Brooks, a ver, son todos jugadores que a día de hoy en sus equipos tienen minuto de calidad.
Sí, y Brian Johnson, por ejemplo, es importante en el Tottenham, Nico Williams es importante en el Forest,
Ben Davis ha pasado, yo creo, un poquito más ya, no sé, segundo o tercer plano incluso.
Sí, pero bueno, siempre me ha parecido como un buen activo para el Tottenham.
Y para lo que voy es que venimos de una aburría, de una alineación tan rara que esto me parece una maravilla.
Se vienen alineaciones raras, ¿vale?
Estamos ya en orden, ¿no?
Estamos ya en orden.
O sea, esto para ti es el peor, ahora este es el segundo peor.
Sí.
Me acuerdo.
Vale, bien, ¿no?
Por ahora.
El tercer peor es Bélgica.
Coño.
Con lo que ha sido Bélgica.
Para lo que ha quedado.
En la Premier League con Lukaku, con De Bruyne, con Courtois en su momento, aunque Mads Sels está bien.
Sus dos centrales no han debutado esta temporada en la Premier League, ¿vale?
Hannes del Croix y Sebastián Bornau, nada de nada.
Leandro de Trossard de 9 porque no tiene 9.
Y he puesto a Mike Tresor, que tampoco ha debutado esta temporada en la Premier League,
de extremo derecha, aunque he dejado 10 partidos ahí por poner a Doku en su posición.
Sí, a ver, bueno...
Tiene Mads Laviaonana, está bien.
Los dos laterales son competentes.
Sels es buen portero.
Sí, bueno, bien, mejor que Gales.
Mejor que Gales, pero me huelo que no va a ser muy difícil quitarte encima de Bélgica.
Es justo el año para hacer este vídeo, que le hemos quitado a Kevin De Bruyne.
Claro.
Pobre gente.
Que ahí tendría más encaje porque tiras a Tressor al suelo y pones a Trossard y a Doku
y haces un rombo con Tienes Mads Laviaonana y De Bruyne.
Lo sentimos, no ha sido posible.
Los gofres y las patatas fritas están ricas, pero no han tenido éxito este año en la Premier League.
Sí, nos comimos uno cuando fuimos hace poco.
Estuviste en septiembre, ¿no? En el Parón.
Sí.
¿En dónde? ¿En Brujas?
En todos lados. Estuvimos en Brujas, en Gante y en Bruselas.
Si quieres.
Te coges ahí el tren, nos dimos cuenta.
Hubo un tren que dijimos que bien están los trenes de Bélgica.
Y en cuanto nos bajamos nos dimos cuenta de que nos salvamos porque el revisor no pasó,
pero estábamos en la zona absolutamente VIP.
Y no teníamos ni idea.
Todo el viaje diciendo que gusto de trenes.
Que gusto de asiento, ¿no?
De verdad, que vistas, que amplitud.
Y luego salimos, a coño, es que es el VIP.
Es ilegal. Lo hicimos de una manera...
¿Pero te traes billete para el tren?
Sí, sí.
Vale, vale. Es que esta es otra.
No jodas.
Bueno, en Alemania hay gente que lo hace.
Pero nos subimos ahí a...
Porque a veces no hay revisores.
Pensamos que era lo típico de...
Pues no está enumerado, yo qué sé, o nos equivocamos.
Nos fuimos arriba y luego diciendo...
¡Vaya, viaje premium! Nos hemos pegado.
Bueno, recomendado Bélgica.
Viaje, sí.
Lo de los gofres y las patatas y tal.
O sea, lo de las patatas...
En el cono, ¿no?
Sí.
Ok con eso.
Son patatas, no?
Bueno, tal.
Pero...
Los gofres están ricos.
Pero sí.
Y luego...
Los gofres que les meten como una especie de KitKat.
Sí.
Se los atraviesan.
Y todo eso ganaba bastante.
Pero ¿con qué eran las patatas?
Ahora no me acuerdo.
Las patatas tienen una salsa a veces...
No, pero eran con algo.
Eran sobre algo.
O con pimento no...
Yo es que he tomado...
Yo he llegado a tomar cucuruchos de patatas solo.
Pero no eran patatas porque sí.
No tenía nada.
Hay una cadena muy conocida de Bélgica y del centro de Europa que es de patatas fritas.
Entonces hay veces que pueden tener o salchichas o cosas por el estilo.
Puede ser que no, que no tuvieran nada.
Pero a mí las patatas...
Sí, así como en recipiente...
El cubo este.
No, en recipiente así como de cartón.
Sí, con hitos de patatas.
Bueno, en fin.
A veces le echan una salsa por encima y tal.
En fin, no es por nada.
Pero es que en Europa te sales de los dominios del Mediterráneo y lo que la gente llama comida...
Francia es el salva.
Pero claro, Francia toca el Mediterráneo.
Toca el Mediterráneo.
Se lo concedo.
Y aún así un escalón por debajo.
Superioridad absoluta griega, española, italiana...
Total.
Y también la portuguesa.
Portuguesa, mirad.
Que es la siguiente del vídeo.
Mira que bien emocionado.
Que no son mediterráneos, pero bueno, pues lo compramos.
Ahí lo tenemos.
Fabio Carballo delantero-centro.
Problemas...
Es el que más partidos ha jugado delantero-centro de los tres.
Perfecto.
Luego, esta reconversión que ha hecho Guardiola con Mateus Nunes se agradece.
Muy bien te ha venido.
Me ha venido de forma espectacular.
Fantástica.
Hay que decir que la línea defensiva no está mal.
A ver, no hay ninguna línea que sea dramática.
No, a mí yo se sabe ya en el año 2025 del calendario oligolano.
Se me queda un poco corto.
Puede ser.
Pero también se me quedaba corto hace dos años.
Pero bueno, sigue parando el hombre algún que otro baloncillo.
Sí, es cierto que dos de los once jugadores son del peor equipo.
A ver, quiero decir, eso se sabe pero no es angusgante.
Quiero decir, pues bueno.
A ver, lo que ha sido Portugal en la Premier se nos queda un poquito corto.
A mí te diría que con un delantero-centro en lugar de Carballo,
creo que lo veríamos con otra forma.
Pero Portugal a nivel histórico en la Premier te monta a un once.
A Cristiano.
Increíble.
Ojo, si solo fuera Cristiano, pero vamos.
Dani...
Te monta en realidad medio...
Porque entre que te saca y Carballo, Ferreira,
empiezas a sacar jugadores que Mourinho usaba.
Manin.
Bueno, si Maniche, en un once ideal no me entra.
Pero bueno.
No sé si mejor que Dallodd podría...
A lo que voy es que en cualquier caso no es un once representativo
lo que ha sido Portugal en la historia de la Premier.
Aún así, bueno, normal.
Me compras que mejor que Bélgica.
Venga, sí, sí.
Lo mejor del vídeo de momento.
Joder, macho, qué mal estamos.
Es duro, eh.
Os digo, esta es la octava selección, eh.
Sí, hombre, pero tiene que ser mejor que Bélgica.
Tienes a Rubén Díaz, Bruno Guimara, perdón, Bruno Fernández,
Bernardo Silva, todos ellos.
Pero Neto...
Los considero leyendas de su club.
Y que todavía siguen rindiendo, pero Neto es un extraordinario jugador.
Paella, Paella está contra hasta ahí.
Si han quedado fuera, Rodrigo Gómez, Mateus Fernández o Es Hugo.
Es cierto que no ha debutado todavía, pero bueno,
Es Hugo, por lo que vimos el año pasado en la Liga, tiene muy buena pinta.
No podrían haber entrado en el once, pero tiene muy buena pinta y son muy prometedores.
Muy bien, vamos al siguiente.
Y aquí a nuestros amigos de LATAM.
Quizá no les gusta que aparezcan tan pronto.
Que es Argentina, pero es que, muchachos, tenéis unos problemas tremendos.
Ostras.
No hay lateral derecho, ¿vale? No hay lateral derecho y no hay delantero centro.
Entonces, la delantera es, en carnacho, mi buen día.
Hombre, no es ideal.
Yarnacho, según Transomark, tiene un partido jugado como delantero centro.
Y al pobre y mi buen día le estás poniendo tan arriba.
A ganar balones ahí en el área.
Carrereros, Julio Soler y Buenanote.
Julio Soler, recordemos, de origen paraguayo, pero que va con la selección.
Pero problemas, eh, problemas, problemas.
Centro del campo y defensa, yo creo que bien.
Estamos Dibu, Senesi, Licha, Cuti, Macalí, Sternikov y Enzo.
Enzo es top, con una vertebral.
A mí toda la línea defensiva y el centro del campo me parece, vamos, lo mejor que hemos visto de largo.
El problema es, pues eso.
O sea, es que todos ellos, Julio Soler no.
Pero buen día, Garnacho, Buenanote, digamos, en esa curva.
Todos ellos me parecen que están teniendo una carrera decente en la Premier.
Decente como mínimo.
Que hay diferencias, Buenanote todavía no ha explotado como explotó en su vida Buen día.
Sí, sí.
Pero...
Y Garnacho a mí se me está quedando un poco por el camino estos últimos años.
Sí, igual, pero bueno.
Sí.
Anda que mi carrera es peor, es que me he ganado macho.
Por eso, sí, sí, claro.
Pero me parece, este me parece más empatado de lo que parece con Portugal.
Se han quedado fuera, por decirlo.
Charlie Alcaraz y Guido Rodríguez.
Bueno, es que Guido, su carrera en la Premier es terrible.
Las cosas como son.
Y Charlie Alcaraz...
Es que no sé si podría hacer de cambio.
Estaba pensando la manera de sacar a Julio Soler para meter a Charlie Alcaraz, pero es imposible.
Si ponemos a Charlie Alcaraz a subir y bajar la banda.
Lo de Buenanote Carrilero ya está siendo...
A jugado de extremo.
A jugado de extremo Buenanote.
Bueno, puede haber debate respecto a Portugal.
Sí, puede haber.
Puede haber debate, aunque solo sea por el Portugal es un once un poco más...
Hecho.
Ordenado.
Pero por ese centro del campo de esa defensa te lo compro, que Argentina está por encima.
Licha, por cierto, que no parece él, lo ha hablado con Jesús antes y parece otra persona completamente opuesta.
Lo ves de hecho.
Muy bien.
Ahora, la siguiente.
Que quizá me han tirado un poco los colores ponerla a un escalón por encima con Argentina.
Ahora viéndola de nuevo.
Vamos allá.
Que es Alemania.
Porque es cierto que esto es una pinza galáctica en toda regla.
A ver, a ver, a ver.
Pero cómo tienes tan poca vergüenza.
Línea de tres.
Andrés, esto no puede estar por encima.
Maliccio.
Esto no puede estar por encima.
Argentina.
Tú no tienes vergüenza ni la conoces.
Pañolada.
Eso saca un pañuelo.
Pañolada infame.
Vitaly Janes y Jordan Bayer.
No puede ser.
Rollstah.
Muy bien.
Sobre todo Stah.
Acabas de perder toda la credibilidad que te quedó.
Brutal shab de extremos carrileros.
Qué vergüenza estoy pasando.
Havertz, Vóltemade.
Es cierto que ahora que lo estoy viendo de nuevo debería estar por debajo de Argentina.
No, no.
Saber lo peor es que creo que está por debajo de Portugal.
No, eso no te lo compro.
Eso no te lo compro.
Está por debajo de Portugal.
El ataque es infinitamente mejor que el de Portugal.
Madre mía de mi vida.
Qué vergüenza estoy pasando.
Es duro.
A ver.
Es que no tienes vergüenza.
Has puesto a Shadaya Gruda de carrileros.
Me has metido a Roll.
Es que aquí impongo si no.
Pues eso.
Está por debajo de Portugal.
La otra opción.
Lo único que te puede salvar es que tienes a Vóltemade arriba un delantero que cada
partido de juego marca un gol.
Lo último.
Lo único que se puede hacer es quitar a Roll, bajar a Havers de interior.
Claro, el centro de campo.
Tú no tienes vergüenza.
Y poner a Fulcuk arriba porque he dejado fuera a Niklas Fulcuk.
Si preguntas por el London Stadium te dicen que es el mejor del planeta.
Y que es por Kron.
Andrés, esto está por debajo de Argentina.
Está por debajo de Argentina y de Portugal.
Portugal no sé.
De Argentina seguro.
Te queda un minuto para convencerte de que es el mejor Portugal.
A ver, ponme el de Portugal.
Jesús, yo creo que si ahora nos pones la imagen de Portugal, Andrés se va a dar cuenta
de que es el mejor Portugal en Alemania.
Véz, Vóltemade, Havertz, Gruda, Shadaya.
A ver, ponme Portugal de nuevo y voy uno por uno.
Que me lo sé de memoria.
Berleno es mejor que Jose Sah.
Vale.
Luego, claro, el tema es que es línea de cuatro contra línea de cinco.
Pero Nunes contra Gruda, Nunes.
Dalot contra Shadaya.
Esto me lo compras.
Pero cómo que...
Pero cómo vas a enfrentar a Shadaya contra Dalot.
¿Dalot de enfeces?
De carrerero.
¿Pero qué dices?
Para el objetivo que tiene Jürgen A. de Schmank con esa selección de Alemania.
¿Qué dices?
Vale, empate.
Qué vergüenza.
Vale, Totti contra Malic Tio.
Hombre, Malic Tio lleva un partido y lo ha hecho muy bien.
Pero es mejor que Totti.
Pero Totti lleva buenas temporadas en los gols completas.
Rubén Díaz.
Bueno, Totti.
Rubén Díaz, para mí es Malic Tio.
Rubén Díaz.
Si quieres hacemos un empate.
Y Tiao es del Newcastle, ¿eh?
Y me ha gustado mucho por ahora.
Rubén Díaz contra Jordan Beyer.
No hay discusión, ¿vale?
Jordan Beyer, no es broma.
Luego, centro del campo.
Bruno, bueno, no, Pagina contra Vitaly Janel.
Pagina.
Florentino.
Madre mía.
Contra Anton Stag.
Stag.
Los dos llevan un mes en la Premier League.
Por eso, por eso.
Y tampoco te creas que es una victoria increíble.
Bruno Imaráes contra Merlin Rol.
Bruno Fernández, que a mí se nos ha escapado bien.
Ya te he metido en la cabeza.
Contra Guillermo, contra Rol.
Es increíble.
Vamos 4-2.
Y ahora, Bernardo contra Virch.
Hombre, Bernardo, por Dios.
Bernardo cada día de la semana.
Bueno, está por debajo.
Qué poca vergüenza.
Está por debajo.
Voltemade, Carvalho, Voltemade.
Mil veces.
Y Neto.
Havertz, Havertz.
Pero no tan lejanísimo.
Pero no es tan evidente.
Es un 4-6 esto.
Vamos.
Con un empate.
Que concuerdas.
Sí, sí.
Bueno.
Me han podido los colores.
Alemania, amigos, que no sabemos qué hace ahí.
Hay que bajar los dos puestos.
Me han podido los colores.
Bueno, vamos al siguiente, ahora sí, que es el quinto.
Que es España.
Vale.
Vamos allá.
España tiene.
Me encanta lo que veo en punta.
Hombre.
¿Veis qué ha pasado?
Nos ha caído nieve.
Sí, es que no he encontrado...
¿Qué ha pasado?
Es una bandera como pinterrajeada en pared.
Porque intentaba darle el mismo toque a todas.
Vale, vale, vale.
Pero es la mejor que he encontrado en España.
Fantástico, fantástico.
Rayan Porteria.
Bien.
Hombre, vamos muy bien ahí.
Porro, Cucurella, Pau Torres, Mosquera.
Muy bien.
Vamos con un misil.
Verá que Pau Torres no está en su mejor momento.
Como misil.
Zubimendi, Rodri, Nico González.
Bien, empezamos a caer un poco con Nico, pero bueno.
¿Qué dices?
Andrés, ¿quién nos va a ganar a esto?
Bien.
Ahora pinchamos.
Bueno, cuidao.
Jeremy Pino, Adam Atraure, Merino.
Está teniendo sus partidos buenos, Jeremy Pino.
Adam ha llevado ya una larga carrera en la Premier League.
Y Mikel Merino es su nueve del copón.
Que me lo digan a mí que el otro día al Newcastle le marcó un colazo de cabeza.
Es cierto que Mikel Merino está encontrando su sitio como nueve.
Absolutamente.
Pero, hombre, Adam Atraure en 2025.
Lo que no tengo ninguna duda.
No teníamos nada.
Se han quedado fuera.
Mallenda.
Fer López.
Jorge Cuenca y Alex Giménez.
Ya.
A Giménez le está poniendo ahora bastante.
Pero claro, cuculilla.
Me quedo...
Muy bien, Alex.
Me quedo satisfecho.
Yo pinchamos ahí en el extremo izquierdo.
Lo que está claro es que por ahora a todos los que han venido, les ganamos.
Sí, fácil.
Lo que habla también de cómo España se ha inundado cada vez más.
La Premier League.
Veremos si puede pelear con las siguientes.
Porque en el cuarto puesto, fuera del podio, está la segunda que más jugadores tiene.
Lo que decía antes, cantidad no es calidad.
Que es Francia.
Porque tiene unos problemas.
Hay algunas posiciones que me parecen dramáticas.
Esa portería.
¿Pu Meslier o Areola?
Que no sé qué prefiero.
Areola.
Hombre.
¿Qué me dices?
¿Cómo más prefería Meslier antes que Areola?
En 2025.
Pero si la Meslier es un accidente, apunto suceder siempre.
Hostia, Areola.
Se ha quedado un poquito...
Adme esa misma frase con Ilan Meslier.
Claro.
Debo decir que con Francia me había apuntado varias cosas.
Que si Meslier o Areola...
Bueno, Areola para mí, pero cada día de la semana.
O Dobert o Digné.
Si hay otro día, después del domingo, también sigue siendo Areola.
O Doberto Digné.
Pero bueno...
Andrés, no me estaba fijando.
¿Qué dices?
Digné, coño.
¿Qué te ha pasado con la selección francesa?
A mí me gusta mucho.
Lucas Digné.
Lucas Digné es el lateral izquierdo que ha llevado a la Champions League a las dos.
A mí o Dober me gusta mucho.
Ya lo sé.
Voy a volver a decir una vez más.
A mí o Dober me gusta mucho.
Bueno...
Son las dos posiciones con las que tenía dudas.
Son las posiciones con las que tenía dudas.
Areola por Meslier y Digné por O Dobert, en mi opinión.
Aún así...
Gyoro, Salé, Baiconaté.
A mí me parece que es...
Se quedan fuera, más es la cruda, por ejemplo.
Podría ser perfectamente la línea defensiva de Francia en algún partido.
De la selección francesa.
Malogusto por derecha.
Con sus luces y sombras.
No me vais a descubrir ahora que no soy fan de Malogusto.
De hecho, igual la clave era
tirar a Malogusto y poner a O Dobert.
O Dobert tenía que entrar.
Luego, Buakar Kamara,
Enzo Lefe...
Hay pincha un poquito Francia.
Sobre todo porque tampoco había muchas alternativas.
Tengo muchas dudas de que esto sea mejor que España.
Y luego arriba,
Cherki, Ekitike, Mateta.
El ataque es mejor que el de España.
Sí, pero todo lo demás...
La defensa es...
Yo creo que Gyoro, Salé, Baiconaté
son mejores que Pau Torres y Mosquera, por ejemplo.
Pero, por ejemplo,
el viaje que les pegamos en los laterales
no tiene nombre.
Porque Tascar Gavini...
Si estuviera Gavini no lo tendría tan claro.
En la portería les pegamos un viaje
y en el centro del campo
es un viaje, aunque solo sea por Rodri Zubimendi.
Yo entiendo que Nico no ha sido brillante
en la Premier, pero solo con Rodri Zubimendi
y les pegamos un viaje.
Me parece que está...
Puede ser un empate técnico.
Pero...
Uff...
Es que nos condena el ataque, pero...
Jesús, ¿tú qué ves entre España y Francia?
Muy igualado.
Uff...
Es que es muy igualado porque
el ataque son 3 de 3 para ellos.
Sí.
La defensa pueden ser...
Esto es línea de 3
y el otro es línea de 4.
Pero...
Salivá, Conat y Lloro son mejores que
en Pautor, Résemosqueda.
Depende de cómo ajustes
porque tienes que poner a uno de los centábales de pivote.
Nosotros ganamos en los laterales
en la portería y en el centro del campo.
Eso son 5 jugadores.
Contra 6 de Francia.
Está muy empatado esto.
Está ahí.
Por eso no he dicho que fuera muy evidente.
Está Kukureya.
Incluso estando Diñe...
En este escándalo que has montado.
Wilson o Dobert...
Te van a dar una caña en comentarios con este cd, Francia.
Pero lo he preparado.
No me he olvidado de Diñe.
He escogido a Wilson o Dobert.
Ya veréis.
En 2027, cuando...
En 2028, cuando Dobert sea titular
en la Eurocopa de 2028,
ahí todo el mundo verá...
Porque a los genios nunca se les comprende
en el momento cuando lo hacen.
Los genios se les comprende a posterior.
Entonces la gente vendrá este vídeo y dirá
Andrés, qué buenos Wilson o Dobert.
Pero no es ni carrilero ni lateral.
Andrés tenía a Lucas Diñe.
Quería decir, ah, vale, qué bien, Lucas Diñe.
Y ha decidido poner a Wilson o Dobert.
Se ha puesto loco.
Y ha puesto a Ilandes bien.
Es un jugador que yo creo que
no puede andar por lich.
Lo mata.
Y se está en este hombro.
Incluso metiendo a Leo Laidiñe me parece muy apretado.
Yo creo que gana Francia por poquito.
Que le llega la gente en comentarios.
Vamos al top 3.
¿Crees que hay alguna liada con la de Francia?
Yo creo que no.
O la Alemania.
La Alemania es la peor.
Te has puesto ahí...
¿Cómo se llama el himno de Alemania?
Deuxen...
Deuxenlied.
La canción alemana.
Deuxen...
Están por Argentina y Portugal.
Con las que pasan.
Vamos al top 3.
Acho tu padre el once de Alemania.
De hecho lo haría peor.
Brasil, tercero clasificado.
Vale.
Mucho nivel aquí.
¡Fight!
¡Empugno!
¡Ya basta!
Hay dos cosas que pueden chirrear.
Ahí está el tema.
Bruno Guimaras lo tenía seguro.
Con el otro acompañante del doble bote tenía dudas porque no se sabía si...
Paquetá, Joel Linton,
Andrés Santos, Casemiro, Joe Gómez,
Douglas Luiz... o sea hay muchas opciones en el centro del campo para ahora.
Te puedo ofrecer una mano.
Igor Giulio ha jugado como lateral izquierdo.
Y tú, ¿cómo se puede poner de carrero izquierdo a subir y bajar?
Entonces con estos mismos jugadores podrías hacer una línea de cuatro.
Igor Giulio como lateral por la izquierda.
Gabriel y Murillo como centrales.
Y la fantasía es por la derecha.
Habría que buscar si ha jugado algún partido Martinelli en los últimos minutos con el Arsenal como carrilero.
Pero bueno, te pones a Martinelli por la derecha.
Luego yo pondría a Kuña en punta con Estebao por la derecha.
Y Joe Pedro más abajo.
Bueno, Joe Pedro o Kuña.
Cualquiera de los dos como interior junto a Bruno y Paquetá.
Y así, al menos así hay una posición loca.
Que es la de Martinelli.
Y no hay dos.
Porque Igor Giulio lo lanzas al lado.
Y es que es el que tiene más fuerza.
Y es el que tiene más fuerza.
Y no hay dos.
Porque Igor Giulio lo lanzas al lado de la izquierda.
Y no ha cambiado ningún jugador.
Para que lo imaginéis en casa también.
Martinelli me compras que por sus aptitudes como futbolista.
¿Eres Alan Shearer?
¿Ha venido hoy al plató Alan Shearer?
El Alan Shearer alemán.
El Alan Shearer que hace los once de la semana.
Aunque es peor Troidini.
Es mucho peor Troidini con la derecha.
Martinelli me compras que por sus aptitudes y lo rápido que es el cambio de ritmo que tiene.
Puede jugar perfectamente el carrilero.
No me parecería una locura.
Este bau es cierto que no ha tenido carrera como futbolista.
Para probarse el carrilero.
No lo han fichado para ser carrilero.
Luego, Gabriel Murillo.
Igor Giulio queda un poco coja.
Y de hecho, Cuña y Sabiño también los pueden cambiar.
Y se pueden cambiar de banda y les sientan más natura.
Jo Pedro Bien.
Bruno Paqueta Bien.
Mejor once que Francia yo creo.
A ver.
Aunque, Dini.
Este bau es mejor que más robusto.
A ver, aquí lo que veo es que línea por línea tienes a uno de los mejores porteros que ha visto la Premier.
A uno de los mejores centrales de la Premier con Gabriel.
Murillo no está podiendo jugar demasiado este inicio de temporada.
Pero para mí ha sido once ideal de la pasada Premier.
Y Igor Giulio, bueno, lo que es.
Pues una maravilla.
Gracias por venir.
Es un buen momento.
Desde que tuvo su lío judicial que luego ha acabado favorable para él.
Pero ya no es el mismo jugador.
Bruno ha marcado dos bolitos.
A ver si con uno se recupera un poco.
No le niego la calidad, desde luego.
Bruno es una leyenda viva del Newcastle United.
Sabiño me está dejando un poco frío en la Premier.
Pero Cuña, Joao, Pedro tienen una buena carrera en la Premier.
Martinelli, a pesar de todo y que ya le cuesta más ganar la titularidad, tiene una buena carrera en la Premier.
Es decir, este once, sobre todo lo que veo es que nadie...
No hay ningún nombre que digas, madre mía, este lo hemos colado con calzador.
Quizás este vao que lleva poco tiempo, pero este vao tiene un talento impresionante.
Sí, Igor Giulio quizá.
Hay que decir que...
¿Quién te has dejado fuera? A ver si lo podemos acompañar.
Me he dejado fuera a jugadores como Joelinton, Andrés Santos, Casemiro, Joao Gómez Duras, Luis.
Al Hugo me voy, no había caído en esto.
Tú no tienes vergüenza ni a Crozes.
Pero te lo he dicho antes.
¿Y qué hago?
Como a Joelinton del central.
Sí. Vamos a componer esto.
¿Igor Giulio fuera?
Gabriel abajo y Joelinton de pivote.
Reconozco que lo necesitamos.
No, no, es que no hay manera.
No hay ningún lateral izquierdo ni que se le parezca.
No, no, no.
Igual ahora me estoy dejando a un jugador que tenga...
¿A quién más habías dejado fuera?
Y como cosas importantes se van Ilson y Gordiago.
Bueno, estás ya a Ircuña.
Mira, yo me cargaba.
Es que, a ver, eso es midiendo un poco más su carrera en general.
Pero Casemiro creo que ha tenido etapas en el Manchester United realmente buenas como para cargarme a paqueta y poner a Casemiro.
Lo he pensado, ¿eh?
Y he pensado también en Joelinton.
Al final acabo metiendo a Paquetá por un poco de talento futbolístico máximo.
Pero Casemiro puede entrar perfectamente.
Pues mira, para mí fuera Paquetá, dentro Casemiro.
Estoy pensando si Casemiro ha jugado alguna vez de central.
Sí.
Porque yo creo que alguna vez sí ha jugado de central.
Pero no nos ayudan.
Ome, quitamos a Igor Julio, bajamos a Gabriel.
No, bajamos a Gabriel y ponemos a Casemiro como el central por el centro que en el fondo, en las líneas de tres, siempre es como un pivote.
El tema es que no podemos quitar a Igor Julio, entonces esto es un gendro con dos carrileros que no tienen sentido.
Igor Julio tiene que estar.
Tiene que cubrir a Martínez y no a Igor Julio.
Bueno, venga, te compro esta posición.
Pero no lo quiero pensar demasiado.
Pero bueno, Brasil, bien, buen equipo.
Es sólido.
No es mejor que la segunda.
O sea, unas pedradas.
Que es Países Bajos.
Vale en nuestras casas.
Sobre todo a la mía, Alemania y Odober.
Ahora ya tengo que comprar una camiseta de Tottenham de Odober.
Yo creo que es obligatorio.
Vale, Países Bajos, segunda mejor selección.
Que si tuviera un mejor delantero-centro, sería para mí la mejor.
Verbruggen, Timber, Van de Ven, Van Dyck, Jorrel Hathoe, Gravenberg, Chávis Limons, Reinders, Frimpong, de extremo derecho, que es su posición de verdad.
Y ahora Gakbo y Cerci.
Solo me hechirría Cerci.
Me he dejado fuera a Matais Delict,
Sven Bodman, Van Hecke, como centrales, que podrían haber entrado.
Y me he dejado fuera a Kluivert.
Que podría haber entrado en lugar de Cerci y poner a Kluivert por izquierda y a Gakbo delantero.
Pues mira, me parece un once muy potente, pero te lo mejoro quitando a Jorrel Hathoe.
Que todavía lo que hemos visto en la Premium no dice mucho.
Y lo que hago es poner a Timber como lateral izquierdo.
Vale.
Y a Delict por derecha o qué?
No, no, no.
Cambio a...
Pones tres centrales, vale.
Y con tres centrales...
A Frimpong, claro.
Tienes como carrilero por la derecha Frimpong, como carrilero por la izquierda Timber.
Y me da igual, Bodman me parece un central top.
Delict me parece que está en un muy buen nivel con el Manchester United.
Y también está un poco infravalorado.
Pero es que Van Hecke el año pasado ya fue el mejor del Brighton.
Cualquiera de los tres me vale.
Y te sube aún más el nivel.
Pues hacemos línea de tres, quitamos a Hathoe, ponemos a Timber por izquierda, a Frimpong por derecha.
Y luego lo demás es una especie de...
Y hacemos un Gakbo-Cerci arriba.
Sí, no tengo problema.
A mí Cerci es lo que más me sirvía.
El Cerci actual.
Yo confío mucho en su carrera como futbolista, pero es cierto que estos últimos dos años...
Creo que Cerci me gusta más que lo que luego su rendimiento me dice.
Porque es un jugador que me gusta.
Igual nos gusta el concepto del jugador, no nos gusta el jugador en sí.
Para lo que necesita el Manchester United se está quedando un poco corto.
Pero vamos, línea por línea por ahora es el más sólido.
Es muy sólido.
No mejora. Yo creo que con un mejor delantero sería la mejor.
Pero evidentemente sería muy duro.
La selección del país en el que se disputa esta competición no estuviera como la mejor selección.
Hablaría muy mal del nivel de esta selección, que es Inglaterra.
Es la número uno, entiendo.
Tiene más de 150 opciones entre las que elegir.
Y no está mal.
Hay cosas que podría cambiar, como por ejemplo, Luis Kelly por libramento.
Una opción interesante.
Vale.
Se acaba de lesionar libramento.
Sí, pero bueno.
No me podría estar en el bueno de ti.
Luego, Wharton en lugar de ese.
Quizá es una cosa que podría plantear.
Pero bueno, veremos ahora mismo.
Más que nada porque sea más natural.
Sí, porque ese doble pivote es un poco total.
Pero bueno, yo me quedo con ese.
Y luego, cosas que se han quedado fuera.
Jared Brandt, voy.
Si ahora fuera...
Hombre, si nos ponemos se han quedado fuera.
Roger, Solanke, Giff, se han quedado fuera pues 140 jugadores.
A ver, en esta en concreto lo que parece que me es más complicado decirte a quién metería.
Porque es que claro, esto es hacer la convocatoria de la selección inglesa.
A ver, a modo de carrera, por ejemplo.
Delap en lugar de Watkins, pero no...
La carrera de John Stones no te la igualan ni de cerca, ni de aquí, ni de Colwell.
Pero también es pensando un poco en usarlos ahora.
Porque en ese motivo pongo a Walker por encima de Rhys James.
Está Dean Henderson, pero oye, Pickford no da razones tampoco en su rendimiento del Everton para quitarlo.
Entiendo a Henderson.
Es más Henderson que Pickford.
Pero bueno, aquí no me voy a romper mucho la cabeza porque es que hay mil opciones.
Pero es la mejor de...
Hombre, más os vale macho.
Sería tristísimo.
¿Habrá alguna liga con la que esto pase?
Si no, rollo la Liga de Uzbekistán, el mejor país igual es Brasil.
A lo mejor hacemos el ejercicio en España y nos llevamos una sorpresa, no creo.
En España te seguirás saliendo que el mejor país es España, pero...
En Francia también porque hay mucho talento francés, aunque hay 40 pobres.
Más que eso es los extranjeros y se han estado buenos.
¿Almojo alguna...?
Bueno, las Audi.
Bueno, claro.
Las Audi por narices, no sé si montas un 11, pero yo creo que un 11 francés o alguna cosa así te sale.
O la estadounidense.
Y la MLS.
O igual, estoy pensando en la brasileña o la mexicana que por ejemplo tienen mucho dinero.
Cuidado, la brasileña debe tener mucho talento brasileño.
También mucho argentino y uruguayo.
Pues ahí de rascadeta y tal, bueno.
Es un ejercicio interesante.
Bueno amigos, este es el ejercicio atropellado que hemos hecho.
Pensándolo ahora ya, hacerlo con la Champions.
Es más complicado, pero bueno.
Se puede intentar con la Champions.
Ya con la fase final.
Pero siempre que no elijas a Outover por encima de Lucas Diñé.
Ojo, es que Lucas Diñé no está en la Champions.
Algo que sé que va a tener este vídeo es que son comentarios.
Comentarios escandalizados auténticamente por lo que ha sucedido en este vídeo.
Por lo que ha perpetrado.
Yo aviso ya, a partir de ahora se ha abierto el club de fans de Wilson Outover.
El barco ha zarpado.
Estáis a tiempo todavía de subiros.
Vais a pensar que no me gusta Wilson Outover.
Me parece un buen futbolista.
Lo que no me parece es carrilero.
Por encima de Lucas Diñé.
Yo me quedo con Outover.
Escándalo nacional.
Creo que te da muchas más variantes ofensivas que Lucas Diñé.
Y teniendo a Joro con Até y Salibá.
Puedes plantearte.
Tener que malo gusto.
Cierra un poquito más en línea de cuatro.
Y que Outover sea algo más creativo en ataque.
Qué duro está siendo.
Ver a un hombre.
Intentar pelear contra el sol.
Contra el sol.
Soltando puñetazos al sol.
En fin amigos.
Un vídeo más.
Un vídeo más que os esperamos en comentarios para que nos digáis cuál es para vosotros el mejor país.
Cómo nos ordenaréis vosotros.
Dónde pondréis Alemania.
Última.
Y nos vemos en el próximo vídeo.